Hey everybody, Ira Glass here. Today on the radio show we have stories about people who are very, very amazingly slow to react in life-changing situations. And to kick off the show we considered all kinds of ideas, but in the end I think there was really only one real possibility. Like the rest of America, we, at This American Life are not tired yet of those stories of women who have no idea that they're pregnant, and then poof! One day, a baby pops out. We are not over that. And yes, the TV I Didn't Know I Was Pregnant is in production for its fourth season right now. We still have questions.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的广播节目我们将讲述一些在人生重大转折面前反应极其缓慢的人们的故事。在节目开始之初，我们考虑了各种各样的想法，但最终我认为只有一个真正的可行方案。就像全美大部分人一样，我们《美国生活》栏目的全体成员还没对那些关于女性“浑然不知自己怀孕，然后砰的一声，孩子就出生了”的故事感到厌倦。我们还没看够。没错，电视节目《我不知道我怀孕了》现在正在制作第四季。我们依然存有疑问。
And that's what a lot of people, they look  at me like, no way. You really didn't know? And I'm like, no, really. I really had no idea. And I had no thought of it. I mean I'm a bright girl. I have two degrees. I work full-time. I'm not like some dummy.
很多人看着我的时候都是那种表情，觉得“没可能吧，你真的不知道吗？”我就会说：“不，我是真的不知道，我完全没往那方面想。”我的意思是，我很聪明，有两个学位，有全职工作，我可不是什么笨蛋。
Meet Jennifer Lyne. Or maybe you've already met her on I Didn't Know I Was Pregnant . Or this week on The View . She was 28, working two jobs-- one as a lab technician, one in a clothing store-- when she discovered that she was pregnant. Turned out to be nine months pregnant. She had a baby three days later. She said she didn't suspect for a bunch of reasons. For one, she was on the pill the entire pregnancy.
向大家介绍詹妮弗·莱恩，或者你可能已经在《我不知道我怀孕了》或本周的《观点》节目中见过她了。她28岁时身兼两职——一份是实验室技术员，另一份在服装店工作——这时她才发现自己怀孕了，而且已经是九个月身孕。三天后她就生下了孩子。她说自己没察觉是有原因的。首先，她在整个怀孕期间一直都在服用避孕药。
And I had taken two pregnancy tests over the course of the nine months and both tests came back negative. So near the end of the pregnancy, in almost the ninth month, I finally complained to the doctor and he sent me up for an ultrasound. He questioned if I could be pregnant. And I explained that no, I was on the pill, and that I hadn't had a period for almost a year. Because when I switched from the previous birth control, which was the depro shot and went onto the birth control pill, the period stopped.
在那九个月里我做了两次验孕，两次结果都显示阴性。所以在怀孕快结束时，大概是第九个月，我终于向医生抱怨了身体不适，他安排我做了超声波检查。他询问我是否可能怀孕。我解释说不可能，因为我一直在吃避孕药，而且快一年没来月经了。因为我从之前的避孕方式，也就是长效避孕针换成口服避孕药后，月经就停止了。
And what was the thing, when you went to the doctor, like what did you think was going on?
那么当你去看医生时，你当时觉得自己是怎么了？
I honestly thought I had a tumor. I couldn't sleep on my stomach. That was my complaint for going to the doctor was because I couldn't sleep comfortably anymore. And I kind of felt around on my stomach because I was an EMT previously. So I kind of felt something wasn't right, but I didn't know what exactly.
我真心以为自己长了肿瘤。我无法趴着睡觉，这就是我去医院抱怨的原因，因为我没法舒适地睡觉了。我摸了摸自己的肚子，因为我以前是紧急医疗救护员（EMT），所以我感觉到有些地方不对劲，但我不知道具体是什么。
So you thought like you had like cancer or something?
所以你以为自己得了癌症之类的病？
Yes, absolutely.
是的，完全是这样。
Now when we talked about having you come in for an interview in our story meeting at our radio show, the women on the radio show staff said, we have questions for her. And so four of them are with me here and I want to introduce you. There's Julie Snyder and Jane Feltes and Robyn Semien and Alissa Shipp.
当我们节目的策划会上讨论邀请你来采访时，节目组的女同事们说：“我们对她有很多疑问。”现在有四位同事和我在一起，我想介绍一下她们：朱莉·斯奈德、简·费尔特斯、罗宾·塞米恩和艾丽莎·希普。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[多人同时说话]
And Alissa, you are huge right now. How many months are you?
艾丽莎，你现在肚子好大，你怀孕几个月了？
I am 38 weeks pregnant. Yeah, like eight and a half, nine months pregnant.
我怀孕38周了，也就是八个半月快九个月了。
So they all have a bunch of questions for you. Is it OK that they throw those at you?
她们有很多问题想问你，你介意她们向你提问吗？
Of course. Yeah, absolutely.
当然可以，没问题。
The first question that I had, and maybe it's because I am so pregnant right now, but the thing that I can't understand not feeling is the kicking. And it's not just kicking, it's like you can see an arm or you can feel something and it moves. Did you feel any of that?
我第一个问题是——也许是因为我现在也怀孕了——我无法理解的是，怎么会感觉不到胎动？那不仅仅是踢踹，就像你能看到一只手臂或感觉到某些东西在动。你一点都没感觉到吗？
I don't think my daughter moved a lot. I think she stayed very stationary. Now, mind you, my daughter was 4 pounds 13 ounces. So she was very, very tiny. So I think that has a lot to do with how much I may have felt because she was so small.
我不觉得我女儿动了很多。我认为她一直很安静。你要知道，我女儿出生时只有4磅13盎司，非常非常小。所以我认为这可能和我感觉到的胎动很少有很大关系。
Jennifer, are you kind of big? I don't know how else to ask that.
詹妮弗，你那时候体型比较胖吗？我不知道该怎么委婉地问。
I'm not big now. I was actually a 22/24 when I did have my daughter. So I was quite big. I actually worked in a plus size women's store called Lane Bryant. I was always large like that. Now I've actually lost a lot of weight and I'm down to a size four or a six.
我现在不胖了。事实上，生女儿的时候我穿22/24码的衣服，所以我当时确实很胖。我当时在一家名为Lane Bryant的大码女装店工作。我一直都是那种大码身材。现在我已经减掉了很多体重，穿4码或6码的衣服了。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[多人同时说话]
And she was my reason for losing that weight. The surprise of having a baby, and now I'm like, oh my God. I'm this huge woman. How am I going to take care of my kid? I need to be around for my daughter.
她就是我减肥的动力。生下孩子是个巨大的惊喜，当时我就想：“天哪，我这么胖，以后怎么照顾孩子？我必须为了女儿活得更久。”
But then basically in the end, you were kind of only aware of being pregnant-- your pregnancy lasted like three days.
所以归根结底，你意识到自己怀孕这件事，整个过程大概只有三天。
Three whole days. Exactly. Isn't that the greatest?
整整三天。没错，这难道不是最棒的吗？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[多人同时说话]
Everyone says, well, you had the best pregnancy. You knew for three days. And I said, exactly. You know what I did those three days? I milked it.
每个人都说：“哇，你的孕期最轻松了，只知道怀了三天。”我回答：“没错。”你知道那三天我做了什么吗？我充分享受了这三天。
There were many more questions and to summarize the answers-- no, she was never nauseated. No, her hair did not fall out. No, her breasts did not seem to get bigger. Yes, her ankles did swell up. And yes, she was incredibly exhausted. And the exhaustion, in fact, made her wonder if she was pregnant. But then the pregnancy test told her no, she wasn't. So she dropped the idea.
还有很多问题，总结一下她的回答：不，她从没感到恶心；不，她的头发没掉；不，她的乳房看起来也没变大。是的，她的脚踝肿了；是的，她感到精疲力竭。事实上，这种疲劳感曾让她怀疑是否怀孕，但后来验孕结果说没有，所以她就打消了这个念头。
Wait, were you aware of like the I Didn't Know I Was Pregnant phenomenon. But like, before you became part of it?
等等，在你成为其中的一员之前，你了解过《我不知道我怀孕了》这种现象吗？
I actually used to watch the show.
我以前其实看过这个节目。
Oh you did?
哦，你看过？
I actually used to watch the show. And then when it happened to me, I would discuss it with my girlfriends at work. They said, oh, you should apply for the show. And I said, really? they're like, yeah.
我以前确实看过这个节目。后来这事儿发生在我身上，我就和单位的女同事讨论。她们说：“哦，你应该报名上节目。”我说：“真的吗？”她们说：“是啊。”
But when you saw that TV show before it happened to you, did you feel the same way that most people feel when they hear about you? Like, oh come on, you must have known?
但是当你在事情发生前看到电视节目时，你的感觉是否和大多数人听到你的故事时一样？比如：“得了吧，你肯定知道吧？”
Some of those stories I feel like come on, how could you have not known. Especially women that have already had kids.
有些故事我也觉得——得了吧，怎么可能不知道？尤其是那些已经生过孩子的女性。
I know.
我知道。
Those are where I feel like, come on, how could you have not known, you've already gone through this.
那些故事让我觉得，得了吧，你怎么可能不知道，你都已经经历过一次了。
I believe you.
我相信你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Did friends of yours, after you had the baby, did they say, like, oh, we thought you might be pregnant?
在你生完孩子后，你的朋友们有没有说：“哦，我们当时就觉得你可能怀孕了？”
The only people that actually mentioned a little something along those lines were the women that I worked with at the plus size store. And they said, well, you know, we kind of noticed you were kind of getting a little rounder around the middle. And I was like, oh. And I kind of looked at them and I said, well, why didn't you say anything? And you know how most women look at you like, well, I'm not going to say that to you. Come on.
只有和我一起在大码服装店工作的人提到过类似的话。她们说：“你知道，我们注意到你的腰部确实变粗了一点。”我就说：“哦。”我看着她们问：“那你们为什么不直接说呢？”你知道大多数人都会那种反应，觉得“我才不会跟你说这个，算了吧”。
You're like, in the future, just ask every woman who you might suspect.
你现在就像是在说，以后遇到怀疑的对象，直接问就行了。
Exactly.
正是如此。
In case she doesn't know.
万一她自己也不知道呢。
Yes, America, if you take just one thing away from today's radio program, I hope that that is it. If you see a woman who gets a little heavier, always, always be sure to ask her if she's pregnant. Because she might not know.
是的，各位，如果你们从今天的广播节目中只能带走一件事，我希望就是这个。如果你看到某个女性变胖了，一定要、务必要问她是不是怀孕了。因为她自己可能根本不知道。
Jennifer is not apparently typical of most women who discover they're pregnant at the very end of their pregnancies. I talked to a psychiatrist who specializes in cases related to OB/GYN issues named Nehama Dresner. She's in Chicago. She says she sees three or four women every year who give birth to a baby and then claim they had no idea they were pregnant. She says generally it is not women who suspect it and took pregnancy tests like Jennifer. She said usually it's adolescents who just don't want to believe they're pregnant for all the reasons that you pretty much expect. And that people are interested in these stories because in the end, a baby pops out. It's pretty dramatic. Dr. Dresner says this kind of thing happens all the time in medicine. People choose to ignore, they rationalize, all kinds of changes happening in their bodies. Even big ones.
詹妮弗显然不是大多数在临产前才发现怀孕的女性的典型案例。我采访了一位专门处理产科相关心理问题的心理医生内哈马·德雷斯纳。她在芝加哥，她说每年都会见到三四个生完孩子后声称自己不知道怀孕的女性。她说一般来说，这些人不像詹妮弗那样会怀疑并去验孕。她说通常是些青少年，出于种种显而易见的理由不愿相信自己怀孕了。人们对这些故事感兴趣是因为最终，一个婴儿出生了，这非常戏剧化。德雷斯纳医生说，这种事在医学界经常发生。人们选择忽略，为身体发生的各种变化寻找理由，哪怕是巨大的变化。
The things that I think strike us, as physicians, are the masses, the tumors that are so obvious, or the sore that won't heal, or that mole that looks like the state of Arkansas. You know, things that are obviously not right that either the patient thinks it'll go away, or minimizes what it might mean, or is so afraid of what it might mean that they avoid diagnosis and treatment. People who get a call back from their gynecologists office that they have an abnormal pap smear and don't ever call back to follow up.
让我们医生感到震惊的通常是那些非常明显的肿块或肿瘤，或者久治不愈的溃疡，亦或是像阿肯色州地图形状的痣。你知道，那些明显不正常的东西，患者要么以为它会消失，要么尽可能淡化其意义，要么因为太害怕其含义而避免诊断和治疗。甚至有些女性接到妇科医生打来的电话说宫颈涂片检查异常，却从未回电咨询后续结果。
Wait, wait, wait. But that can't happen very often.
等等，等等。这不可能经常发生吧？
About 30% of the time. About 30% of the time, don't call back.
大约30%的情况会这样。30%的人不会回电。
Wait, the doctor's calling to say that the pap smear--
等等，医生打电话过来说涂片检查结果——
You have an abnormal pap smear, you need to come back in for me to--
“你的宫颈涂片异常，你需要回来复查……”
Because you might have cancer?
“因为你可能得了癌症？”
Right.
没错。
But the people took the test to find out this result.
但这些人明明做了检查就是为了获知结果。
Yes. I mean it's sort of like an annual exam that you have. It's hard to believe. You're asking me how to understand something that's irrational. I can't answer that question for you.
是的。这就好比是年度体检。这很难相信。你问我如何理解某种非理性的行为，我无法为你回答这个问题。
And if people are this way with their own bodies, with things that are sometimes so dangerous to them, what other things are they putting off way too long? Well today on our show, we have three very dramatic examples of what else, including a guy who ends up waiting 17 years before finally marrying the woman he loves. From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. We have amazing stories today of people sidestepping huge, life-changing experiences that they just are not ready to deal with. Until finally, they are. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
如果人们对待自己的身体，对待那些有时危及生命的问题都是这种态度，那他们还在推迟处理哪些事情呢？今天我们的节目中有三个非常戏剧性的例子，包括一个等待了17年才最终娶到心爱之人的男人。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是由国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》。今天我们带来了人们回避那些尚未准备好面对的巨大人生转变的惊人故事。直到最后，他们终于准备好了。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, When I Grow Up.
第一幕，当我长大后。
Back in 2004, a reporter named David Holthouse published this remarkable story in the weekly paper that he worked for back then called Westword. It's about something that he had waited his entire life to do since childhood. But I want to warn anybody listening now with children, we actually don't believe this story is suitable for children. There's nothing graphic in it, but the things that it's about are not right for kids we think. So this is going to take about 20 minutes. We're putting this on the radio because David take us inside the head of somebody, himself actually, who's contemplating things that he admits later are completely reprehensible and wrong. And he explains how he got to that point. And then even more unusual, how he was able to snap out of it. So kids, good bye. And here's David Holthouse.
2004年，一位名叫大卫·霍尔索斯的记者在他当时工作的《Westword》周报上发表了这个非同寻常的故事。这关于他自童年起就等待了一生的事情。但我想提醒现在带着孩子的听众，我们认为这个故事不适合儿童。内容中没有露骨的描述，但其中的主题不适合孩子。这大约需要20分钟。我们把它搬上广播是因为大卫带我们走进了一个人的大脑——实际上就是他自己——他审视着自己后来承认完全是错误且令人发指的想法。他解释了他是如何走到那一步的。更不同寻常的是，他是如何摆脱那种状态的。所以，孩子们，再见。接下来是大卫·霍尔索斯。
This time last year I was plotting to kill a man. This time last year I had a gun, and a silencer, and a plan. I had staked out the man's tract home in the Denver suburbs. I had followed him to and from his job in a high tech office park. I was confident I would get away with murder because there was nothing in recent history to connect me to him. Homicide investigators look for motive and mine was buried 25 years in the past.
去年的这个时候，我正在密谋杀掉一个人。去年的这个时候，我有一把枪、一个消音器和一个计划。我潜伏在他位于丹佛郊区的住宅附近，一路尾随他往返于高科技办公园区的办公室。我确信自己能逃脱罪责，因为最近没有任何历史记录将我与他联系在一起。杀人调查人员寻找动机，而我的动机已经深埋在25年前了。
The man I was going to kill was the one who raped me in 1978 when I was 7 years old.
我打算杀掉的那个人，是1978年在我7岁时强奸我的人。
When I was 7, I had a crush on Princess Leia and wanted to be a member of the rock band Kiss when I grew up. I was in the second grade and a cop dressed up like a bloodhound wearing a trench coat and calling himself McGruff came to my school and warned us all to watch out for strange men in cars offering candy. But McGruff didn't say anything about watching out for the son of my mom and dad's best friends. He was 15 and a star high school athlete. He wrestled and played football. The paper ran a profile of him in the sports section and my mom cut it out and stuck it on our refrigerator. I looked up to him. I thought he was super cool.
7岁那年，我暗恋莱娅公主，长大后想加入摇滚乐队Kiss。我上二年级的时候，有个穿得像猎犬、穿着风衣自称“麦克格鲁夫”的警察来学校警告我们要提防开着车兜售糖果的陌生男人。但麦克格鲁夫没告诉我们要提防我父母好友的儿子。他当时15岁，是高中明星运动员，会摔跤，还会打橄榄球。报纸的体育版刊登过他的简介，我妈妈把它剪下来贴在冰箱上。我很崇拜他，觉得他酷毙了。
One night his parents had my parents over for dinner, and he asked me if I wanted to go to his bedroom in the basement and play with his karate stuff. We snuck off together and once he had me alone inside his room, the door closed, he got out his karate stuff, throwing stars and nunchucks and a curved sword. And we started playing. He did not play nice. He spun the nunchucks inches from my face and hurled the throwing stars into the wall next to me. I didn't know what was going on, but I knew it was bad, so I started crying. And he told me to shut up. Then he started chasing me around the room waving the sword. He put the blade to my throat and backed me into a corner where I dropped into a crouch and cowered.
一天晚上，他父母请我父母吃饭，他问我想不想去地下室的卧室玩他的空手道装备。我们溜了进去，门一关，他取出双节棍、飞镖和一把弯刀。我们开始玩。但他玩得一点都不友好，他在我脸旁几英寸处挥舞双节棍，把飞镖扔在我身边的墙上。我不知道发生了什么，但我知道这很糟糕，所以开始哭。他让我闭嘴，然后挥舞着刀在房间里追赶我。他把刀刃抵在我的喉咙上，把我逼进墙角，我缩成一团，蜷缩着身体。
The term child molestation doesn't begin to describe what happened next. When I think child molestation, I think inappropriate touching. I think fondling. What happened next wasn't fondling. It was rape.
“猥亵儿童”这个词根本不足以形容接下来发生的事。提到猥亵儿童，我会想到不适当的触碰、抚摸。接下来发生的事不是抚摸，那是强奸。
He started off by telling me he'd cut my face with the sword if I didn't do what he wanted. I had no words for what was happening, no concept of rape or sex. I just knew that I was terrified and in pain. When he was done with me he said that if I told my parents, or his parents, or anyone else, that my mom and dad would be very angry with me, because I'd done a bad thing. He said if I told on him he'd come to my house in the middle of the night and gut me like a salmon. Then he opened his door.
他一开始说，如果我不按他说的做，他就会用刀割开我的脸。我当时没有词汇来形容正在发生的一切，对强奸或性没有任何概念。我只知道我恐惧万分，痛苦不堪。当他完事后，他说如果我告诉父母或他父母，或是其他人，我爸妈会对我非常生气，因为我做了坏事。他说如果我告发他，他会半夜来我家，像剖三文鱼一样剖开我的肚皮。然后他打开了门。
He told me not to go back upstairs right away and sat me down in front of a TV in the downstairs family room, and had me play Atari until my tears dried and I was more presentable.
他让我不要马上回楼上，让我坐在楼下的家庭活动室看电视，一直玩雅达利游戏，直到眼泪干了，看起来正常为止。
When I was seven, I no longer believed in the Easter Bunny or the Tooth Fairy. But from that night on, I had no such doubts about the bogeyman.
七岁那年，我不再相信复活节兔子或牙仙子了。但从那天起，我不再对“怪物”有任何怀疑。
He only got me that once, or at least only once when I was conscious. There was one night two or three months later when my parents were hosting a holiday party and they took me to his house so he could babysit me and his little sister. He put on the Saturday Night Fever soundtrack and we played disco, which consisted of all of us getting drunk on straight, warm, hard booze while he watched his little sister and me gyrate to "Stayin' Alive" thereby securing my lifelong hatred of the Bee Gees. I don't remember the rest of that night, just waking up the next morning with my first hangover.
他只抓到我那一次，或者说在我清醒的时候只有那一次。两三个月后的一个晚上，父母举办聚会，他们把我带到他家，让他看管我和他妹妹。他放起了《周末狂热夜》的原声带，让我们跳迪斯科，我们所有人都喝得烂醉，他在一旁看着我和他妹妹随着《Stayin' Alive》起舞，这让我终生厌恶比吉乐队。我不记得那晚剩下的事了，只记得第二天醒来时经历了人生的第一次宿醉。
I made sure he never got me alone again for more than a few minutes, which wasn't easy, because our parents socialized almost every weekend at either their house or ours. And he didn't move out or go to college after high school. He turned into one of those guys who still dates high school chicks and lives with his parents well into his 20s.
我确信他再没机会单独把我带走，这并不容易，因为我们的父母几乎每个周末都在对方家里社交。他高中毕业后没搬走也没上大学，他变成了那种快30岁了还跟高中生约会、住父母家的家伙。
I kept our little secret throughout my childhood. At first, I was scared and ashamed and believed his threats. By the time I was a teenager and understood what he'd done to me in his room, it just seemed easier to keep my mouth shut.
我在整个童年时期都守着这个小秘密。起初，我很害怕、很羞愧，相信了他的威胁。等我长大到理解他在房间里对我做了什么的时候，守口如瓶似乎更容易。
Why make a fuss? Why traumatize my parents? And why risk being viewed as damaged goods?
为什么要闹大？为什么要让父母遭受创伤？为什么要冒着被视为“损坏品”的风险？
My memories of him in those early years are scattershot. One 4 of July he told me how much fun he'd just had torturing a cat with a firecracker. And I remember for years after the rape, whenever he and I were in the same room and no one was looking, he would make an obscene gesture and give me a bogeyman smile. A smile that said, "I got more of this for you, you little 8, 9, 10 year old punk."
我对他在早期几年的记忆支离破碎。有一个7月4日，他告诉我用鞭炮折磨一只猫是多么有趣。记得在那之后的好几年里，每当我和他共处一室而没人看着时，他就会做个下流手势，露出那个魔鬼般的微笑。那个笑容仿佛在说：“小屁孩，我这儿还有更多好东西等着你呢。”
The last time I ran into him was 12 years ago when I was 21. I was back home from college between my sophomore and junior years, and I needed a cheap suit for a job interview. And there he was. A 31-year-old cheap suit salesman and rapist of children. I hadn't seen him in six or seven years and I immediately realized two things.
最后一次遇见他是在12年前，我21岁的时候。大二和大三之间我放假回家，需要买一套便宜的西装去面试，他就出现在那里。一个31岁的廉价西装推销员，一个猥亵儿童的罪犯。我已经六七年没见过他了，我立刻意识到两件事。
The first, was that he was no longer bigger than me. I had 6 inches and at least 30 pounds on him. The second thing I realized was that I wanted to kill him. I wanted to grab a coatrack and bash in his head. Snatch that metal ball point pen out of his cheap suit jacket and stab him in the eye, over and over again. But I did nothing.
第一，他不再比我强壮了，我比他高6英寸，重至少30磅。第二件事是我意识到我想杀了他。我想抓起衣架砸烂他的头，从他便宜的西装外套里掏出金属圆珠笔，一次又一次地刺向他的眼睛。但我什么也没做。
My mother was with me and even more than I wanted revenge, I want to prevent her and my father from finding out that he had raped me when I was seven years old, while they were upstairs with his parents drinking wine and playing board games. I didn't want to burden them with that. I didn't want to tarnish their memories of my childhood. The bogeyman gave a weak smile and made small talk with my mom while I was pretending to look at cuff links on the other side of the store. Then he vanished into a break room after passing us off to another salesman. He wanted no part of me anymore.
我母亲当时和我在一起，比起复仇，我更希望阻止父母发现他在我7岁时强奸了我，而当时他们就在楼上和他父母边喝葡萄酒边玩棋牌游戏。我不想把那份重担加在他们身上，不想玷污他们关于我童年的回忆。那个怪物露出了一个软弱的微笑，跟我妈寒暄了几句，而我假装在商店的另一边看袖扣。然后他消失在休息室里，把我们转交给另一位推销员。他不想再和我产生任何瓜葛。
The memory of being raped when I was seven was never repressed. It was not recovered under hypnosis. It has always been with me, festering. When I was a teenager, I began researching how being raped as a child might affect the development of my personality, and I recoiled in horror. Every study I read supported the vicious cycle theory, that victims of pedophilia are more likely to become pedophiles themselves. I felt like a werewolf had bitten me, and it was only a matter of time before the full moon rose.
7岁被强奸的记忆从未被压抑，也没有在催眠下找回。它一直伴随着我，不断溃烂。青少年时期，我开始研究童年被强奸如何影响性格发育，结果让我惊恐不已。我读到的每项研究都支持“恶性循环理论”，即恋童癖的受害者更有可能成为恋童癖者。我感觉就像被狼人咬了一口，满月升起只是迟早的事。
Throughout my early adolescence, I was constantly, tortuously checking myself for evil impulses. I made a blood oath with myself that if I started feeling the desire to rape children I would kill myself and make it look like a mountaineering accident. I was already in the habit of solo rock climbing. No partners, no ropes, despite my parents' repeated warnings against such a dangerous activity. Had I throw myself down a mountain they would have believed it. And better a son who died climbing than one who lived and rape kids.
整个青春期早期，我都在不断、痛苦地检查自己是否有邪恶冲动。我向自己发下毒誓，如果我开始产生强奸儿童的欲望，我就自杀，并把它伪装成登山事故。我已经有了独自攀岩的习惯，没有同伴，没有绳索，尽管父母反复警告我这样危险。如果我从山上摔下去，他们会相信的。毕竟，死于登山的儿子总好过一个活着去强奸孩子的儿子。
The next death I plotted was his, the boogeyman's.
我密谋的下一个死者就是他，那个怪物。
After I moved to Denver three years ago I learned from my parents that he also lived in the area. I became fixated on the idea that he was raping children nearby and that it was up to me to stop him. I had no evidence, but authorities agree that most pedophiles begin molesting when they're teenagers and most of them never stop. Not even after they're caught. If they're caught. My guy has never been caught.
三年前搬到丹佛后，我从父母那里得知他也住在这附近。我变得固执，认定他还在附近强奸儿童，而我有责任去阻止他。我没有证据，但权威机构一致认为大多数恋童癖者从青少年时期就开始猥亵，而且大多数人从未停止。即使被抓到——如果被抓到的话。而我的目标从来没被抓到过。
According to a 1998 Colorado Bureau of Investigation polygraph study of convicted child molesters, the mean number of victims per molester, at least in this state, is 184. And that's only for the molesters who've been arrested.
根据1998年科罗拉多州调查局对已定罪恋童癖者的测谎研究，该州恋童癖者的平均受害者人数为184人。这还是指那些被逮捕的恋童癖者。
All my adult life I'd been aware that he was, in all likelihood, still raping children. But as long as he was doing it far away, I had felt no compulsion to do anything about it. But once I found out he was here and living nearby, I began to agonize over my failure to stop him. I considered going to the police, but I had no evidence except my memories, and the statute of limitations has long run out for the crime he committed with me.
成年后，我一直意识到他很可能还在强奸儿童。但只要他远在天边，我就没觉得有任何采取行动的冲动。但一旦发现他就住在这附近，我开始为自己未能阻止他而感到痛苦。我考虑过报警，但我除了记忆外没有任何证据，而且他对我犯罪的追诉期早已过期。
I thought about placing subtle advertisements in newspapers. I thought about sending anonymous letters to everyone he knows, his ex-wives and everyone in this new neighborhood in Colorado, warning them and begging them to please come forward if they knew or suspected anything. But I was afraid such measures would somehow lead to my parents finding out. And the cold, hard truth is that I just didn't want them to know.
我考虑过在报纸上刊登隐晦的广告。我考虑过给所有认识他的人——他的前妻、他在科罗拉多的新邻居——寄匿名信，警告他们，恳求他们如果知道或怀疑什么请务必站出来。但我害怕这些措施会以某种方式让我父母发现。冷酷的事实是，我只是不想让他们知道。
My parents are retired, and in their 60s, and they didn't need that. I wanted to protect them more than I wanted to protect children I'd never met.
我的父母已经退休，60多岁了，他们不需要经受这些。我想保护他们的愿望超过了保护我不认识的那些孩子。
The more I obsessed on it, the more I came to the seemingly inescapable conclusion that the best way to make sure he never raped another child, to make sure I had my revenge, was to kill him. To just walk right up to him in a secluded place and scrape him from this world like a piece of dog [BLEEP] off my shoe.
我越执着于此，就越得出一个看似无法逃避的结论：确保他永远不会再强奸另一个孩子，确保我获得复仇的唯一方法，就是杀了他。在隐蔽的地方直接走到他面前，像鞋底的狗屎一样从这个世界上抹除他。
I bought the gun last April. I had a few firearms in my closet already, but they'd all been purchased legally in my name from a licensed firearm's dealer. I make my living as a reporter. My assignments at the time routinely brought me into contact and sometimes friendship with unsavory characters, including the leaders of a street gang. So I went to their barrio where I bought a Beretta 9 millimeter with a homemade silencer and the serial number removed. I took this gun to the local garage gunsmith and had him put dozens of deep nicks and grooves in the Beretta's barrel to corrupt ballistics tests.
去年四月我买了枪。我的壁橱里已经有几把枪了，但都是从持牌枪支经销商那里合法购买的。我以记者为生，当时的任务经常让我与一些名声不佳的角色接触，有时还会成为朋友，包括一个街头帮派的头目。所以我去了他们的社区，买了一把带有自制消音器的贝雷塔9毫米手枪，序列号已被磨掉。我带着枪去当地的枪匠那里，让他给枪管刻了几十道深深的划痕和凹槽，以破坏弹道测试。
After testing the gun and silencer in the desert, I put them in storage and kept scheming.
在沙漠中测试过枪支和消音器后，我把它们存了起来，继续筹划。
It seemed insane to me now that I was actually going to kill a man instead of just bringing out in the open what he had done to me. But that's how kiddie rapers get away with it. They depend upon shame and embarrassment to keep their victims quiet. By the time I was an adult, I feared that if my friends knew my secret they wouldn't trust me around their children. And parents need to be watchful. The commonly accepted estimate among law enforcement and sexual abuse treatment specialists in Colorado is that 1 in 4 women and 1 in 6 men who live in this state were either molested or raped before the age of 18. Most of them by men or teenage boys they knew. By coaches, scout masters, priests, family friends, sons of family friends.
现在看来，我居然为了不把真相公布于众而要杀人，简直疯了。但这正是那些猥亵儿童的家伙能够逍遥法外的原因，他们依赖羞耻感和尴尬来让受害者保持沉默。成年后，我担心如果朋友们知道我的秘密，他们就不会放心地让我接近他们的孩子。父母需要保持警惕，科罗拉多州执法部门和性虐待治疗专家普遍估计，该州有1/4的女性和1/6的男性在18岁之前曾遭受猥亵或强奸。大多数受害者是被他们认识的人、高中教练、童子军领队、神父、家庭朋友或家庭朋友的儿子侵害的。
So this time last year I was plotting to kill a man, and I was telling myself that it was noble. I was doing it to protect the children. But really, more than anything else, I think I just wanted to shoot the son of a bitch. And I believe I would have, taking a second deep and dirty secret with me to the grave. But then my parents found out just in time to prevent me from committing first degree murder.
所以去年的这个时候，我正在谋划杀人，还告诉自己这很崇高。我是为了保护孩子们。但说真的，我觉得我只是想开枪射杀那个杂种。我相信我本来会这么做的，带着第二个深沉而肮脏的秘密进坟墓。但后来我的父母及时发现了这一切，阻止了我的蓄意谋杀。
If you have a secret you want to keep, never write it down. I know that now, but I didn't when I was 10, the summer between fourth and fifth grade when I sat down with a pen and my Garfield the cat diary. The entry is dated June 1981. And while I have no memory of writing it, the penmanship is unmistakably my own. There, between accounts of my grandfather dying and a game winning double I hit in little league, is an account of my being raped three years before. I concluded the entry by wondering what I would do if I ever met the man who had raped me on the street once I myself was a grown man.
如果你有什么想要保守的秘密，千万别写下来。我现在知道了，但我10岁时不知道，那是四年级升五年级的暑假，我拿起笔和我的《加菲猫》日记本。那一页的日期是1981年6月。虽然我不记得自己写过，但这笔迹毫无疑问是我自己的。在那一页里，记载着我祖父的去世和小联盟中我击出制胜双安打的故事，还有我对三年前被强奸的记叙。我写道，如果我作为一个成年人，在街上遇见那个强奸犯，我该怎么办？
Will I smile and shake his hand and pretend nothing happened? I wrote. Or will I punch him in the face?
我会微笑着和他握手并假装什么都没发生吗？还是会一拳打在他的脸上？
Last September my mom and dad decided to spend part of Labor Day weekend going through the cabinets in my old bedroom and box up all my childhood stuff for attic storage. My mom found the diary and read it. She told my dad. I received a frantic message from her on my voice mail saying I needed to call home right away. They told me about finding the diary. Then my mom asked in a shaking voice if it was true. Had I had any warning, I would have lied. But I was not prepared, and so I told the truth.
去年九月，我爸妈决定利用劳动节周末整理我旧卧室里的橱柜，把童年的杂物装进箱子放进阁楼。妈妈发现了日记并读了它。她告诉了爸爸，我收到了她留在语音信箱里的一条充满恐慌的信息，说我必须马上给家里回电。他们告诉了我发现日记的事，然后妈妈颤抖着问这是不是真的。如果我有任何预警，我会撒谎的。但我毫无准备，所以说了实话。
My mom started crying, and I said I'd fly home as soon as I could. I'd scheduled the murder by then, giving myself a 72-hour window immediately before I was to leave on a two-week trip to Mexico in late December. My plan was to shoot him, ditch the gun, then fly out of the country and keep my ear to the ground from afar just in case. There's an ill-kept baseball field near his house where I was going to stalk him on a late-night walk. It's a good place for a killing in the suburbs. Quiet, usually empty, and hundreds of yards from the closest house on its far side.
妈妈开始哭泣，我说我会尽快飞回家。那时我已经预订了谋杀计划，给自己留出了去年12月下旬前往墨西哥进行两周旅行前夕的72小时窗口期。我的计划是开枪射杀他，扔掉枪，然后飞出国境，在远方听取动静。他家附近有个维护不善的棒球场，我打算在他深夜散步时尾随他。在郊区，那是杀人的好地方，安静，通常没人，离远处最近的房子有几百码远。
But now, because of my parents, I called off my plan. The truth was now out. It was my mother who let it out. She called the boogeyman's parents who now live in the Midwest. She started off by saying that what she was about to tell them would be difficult for them to hear, but for the sake of their grandchildren they should listen. The bogeyman has children of his own now, as well as stepchildren.
但现在，因为我父母的关系，我取消了计划。真相已经大白了。是我母亲泄露出去的，她给住在中西部的那个怪物的父母打了电话。她说接下来的话可能会很难听，但为了他们孙辈的利益，他们必须听下去。那个怪物现在也有了自己的孩子，还有继子女。
She told them that their son had violently raped me in the fall of 1978. She told him that he had used a knife. She told them that the typical number of victims for a pedophile his age is well over a hundred. She told them that she regretted finding out what their son had done to me, but now that she had she felt that they had to know as well. She told them that she wished them to have good lives, but to never contact her or my father again. No Christmas cards, nothing. She told them she hoped their son eventually got caught and spent the rest of his life getting raped in prison. Then she hung up.
她告诉他们，他们的儿子在1978年秋天暴力强奸了我。她告诉他们，他用了一把刀。她告诉他们，他那个年纪的恋童癖者平均受害者人数超过一百人。她告诉他们，她很后悔发现了他们儿子对我做的事，但既然知道了，她觉得他们也有必要知道。她祝愿他们生活幸福，但永远不要再联系她或我父亲。没有圣诞贺卡，什么都没有。她说她希望他们的儿子最终被抓，在监狱里度过余生。然后她挂断了电话。
By then, I'd begun writing about how I was sexually assaulted as a child, all the while knowing that I would never get to the bottom of it and really understand what had happened if I did not at least try to confront the bogeyman. I was a lot more comfortable with the concept of shooting him in the head than I was with talking to him on the phone, let alone in person.
在那之前，我开始撰写关于我童年如何受到性侵害的文章，心里清楚如果我不至少尝试去面对那个怪物，我就永远无法触及底部，真正理解发生了什么。比起在电话里和他说话，更不用说面对面，我对一枪打碎他的头这个概念感到自在得多。
On May 5, I finally sent two copies of the same letter to his house. One by overnight Airborne Express, one by registered mail. It began, "Remember me? Our parents were good friends. I remember my childhood years very, very well. Especially a certain night when I was seven, when your parents had my family over for dinner and you and I went down to your bedroom to play with your karate stuff. I kept what you did to me a secret for 25 years. It's time for you and I to talk this over. I suggest a meeting in public, anywhere in the Denver metro as soon as possible.
5月5日，我终于寄了两份同样的信到他家。一份通过隔夜空运，一份通过挂号信。开头写着：“还记得我吗？我们的父母是好朋友。我的童年记忆非常清晰，特别是七岁那年的一晚，当你父母邀请我们家吃饭时，我们去了你的卧室玩空手道装备。你对我做的事情，我隐瞒了25年。现在是我们谈谈的时候了。我建议尽快在丹佛市区找个公共场所会面。”
"If seeing me face-to-face is too uncomfortable for you, then at least call me. Simply ignoring this letter is not going to work. If I don't hear from you by Friday late afternoon, I'll start calling your house, and then knocking on your front door. I want to be perfectly clear here, I'm not threatening you with any physical harm, and I'm not hinting at blackmail. I don't want your blood or your money, just one uncomfortable conversation."
“如果面对面让你感到不适，那么至少给我打电话。简单的忽视这封信是行不通的。如果星期五傍晚还没收到你的回复，我会开始给你家打电话，然后敲你的前门。我要说清楚，我不是威胁你人身安全，也不是勒索。我不想要你的血或钱，只需要一次令人不适的谈话。”
He received the letters and phoned me all in the same day. I told him that I appreciated his calling me and that I was surprised he had.
他收到了信，并在同一天给我打了电话。我说我感谢他的致电，而且我很惊讶他会这么做。
"Well," he said, "it's a call I should have made a long time ago."
“好吧，”他说，“这是一通我早该打的电话。”
I was stunned because from his words and tone of voice it sounded like he was going to actually admit what he'd done when I knew that almost all pedophiles deny, deny, deny until the day they die.
我惊呆了，因为从他的话语和语气中听起来，他真的要承认他所做的一切，而我明明知道几乎所有的恋童癖者都会在死前一直否认。
We arranged to meet at 2:00 pm the following afternoon at a Cracker Barrel near his house.
我们约定第二天下午2点在离他家附近的一家Cracker Barrel见面。
"Is there anything you want to say to me now?" I asked.
“你现在有什么想对我说的吗？”我问。
"Just that I'm deeply sorry," he said. "I've thought a hundred times about contacting you in the last 20 years to tell you that, but I just never had the courage to pick up the phone. I'm sorry for the pain I've caused you, and my parents, and your parents."
“只是我很抱歉，”他说。“过去20年里，我曾一百次想到要联系你告诉你这一点，但我从没勇气拿起电话。我很抱歉，为你、为我的父母、为你的父母带来的痛苦。”
He sounded sincere, well rehearsed. The next day, an hour before we were supposed to meet, I changed the location from a chain restaurant in suburbia to the intersection of the 16th Street Mall and Market Street in downtown Denver. He showed up wearing jeans, a grey t-shirt, and a Colorado Avalanche cap. When I saw him standing on the corner anxiously trying to pick me out of the crowd, I realized the moment I had written about in my diary in 1981 had arrived. We were both grown men and I was meeting him on the street.
他听起来很真诚，像是排练过。第二天，在我们预定会面的前一小时，我把地点从郊区的连锁餐厅改到了丹佛市中心的第16街购物中心与市场街的交叉口。他穿着牛仔裤、灰色T恤和科罗拉多雪崩队的棒球帽出现。当我看到他焦虑地在人群中搜寻我时，我意识到我在1981年日记中写下的那个时刻到来了。我们都是成年男子，我在大街上遇见了他。
I didn't punch him in the face. I did shake his hand. But neither of us pretended that nothing had happened. We were afraid of one another. I was so jacked up on adrenaline I was shaking. He was sweating like he'd just run a mile.
我没打他的脸，确实握了他的手。但我们俩谁也没假装什么都没发生。我们都在恐惧对方。肾上腺素激增，我的手在颤抖。他流着汗，就像刚跑了一英里。
"Nervous," he said. I nodded. "Me too," he said.
“紧张吧？”他说。我点头，“我也是，”他说。
We walked around the block, and he started by telling me that he'd been waiting for me to contact him for several weeks. Soon after my mom had called his parents in March, he said, they'd flown to Colorado and confronted him. He told me that he'd admitted he had raped me to both his parents and his wife.
我们在街区周围走了一圈，他开始告诉我，他等我联系他已经好几周了。他说3月份我妈给我他父母打电话后，他们飞到科罗拉多找他对质。他告诉我，他向父母和妻子承认了曾强奸我。
"My mom got extremely emotional and didn't handle it well at all. And my dad just went quiet and became very stoic," he said. "They've sort of written me off since then. They used to call me every week, but they don't call me anymore. Even though I told them it had only happened with you that once."
“我妈变得非常情绪化，完全无法接受。我爸沉默了，变得异常坚忍，”他说。“从那时起，他们就基本上跟我断绝关系了。他们以前每周都给我打电话，现在不打了。尽管我告诉他们，那件事只发生在你身上一次。”
He made this claim repeatedly during our conversation, working it into his response to nearly every question I asked. He only had one victim-- me. He had not sexually assaulted any other child before or since.
他在我们的谈话中反复强调这一说法，几乎在回答我提出的每一个问题时都会提到。他只有一个受害者——我。在此之前或之后，他从未猥亵过任何其他孩子。
We sat on the mall's stone stools and kept talking, our voices low. Both of us looking around to make sure no one was in ear shot. I asked him how his wife had reacted. "She was concerned, obviously," he said. "She wanted to know right away if our son was safe, and I told her, yes, he is."
我们坐在购物中心的石凳上继续低声谈话，两人都在环顾四周，确保没人能听到。我问他妻子有什么反应。“她显然很担心，”他说，“她立刻想知道我们的儿子是否安全，我告诉她，是的，他很安全。”
Then I hit him with the question I'd always wanted to ask. "Why did you do it?" He shook his head and tears welled in his eyes.
然后我问了他那个我一直想问的问题：“你为什么要这么做？”他摇了摇头，眼眶里溢出了泪水。
"I've asked myself that question over and over and over again, David. And I just don't have a good answer for you. I wish I did, but I just don't know. I know that until I was in my 30s, I didn't really believe other people's feelings were real. I didn't think anyone really mattered but me. Maybe that was it. Maybe if I'd gone to therapy I could have come up with the answer. All I can say is that I'd never done it before and I never did it again. And if there was one thing I could go back in my life and change, that would be it."
“我一遍又一遍地问自己那个问题，大卫。但我真的给不出好的答案。我希望有，但我真的不知道。我知道直到30多岁，我都没真正相信别人的感受是真实的。我以为除了我之外，没人真正重要。也许就是这样。如果我当时去接受治疗，也许能找到答案。我只能说，我以前从没做过，以后也再没做过。如果生命中有什么事能让我重回过去去改变，那就是这件事。”
I asked if his attack on me was spontaneous or planned.
我问他攻击我是否是自发的还是预谋的。
"It wasn't planned," he said, "I just acted on this one weird impulse. As soon it was over, I was, thinking, oh my God. That's my little sister's friend. How could I have just done that?"
“没有计划，”他说，“我只是受到了一种奇怪的冲动驱使。事情结束后，我立刻想，‘天哪，那是小妹妹的朋友。我怎么会做出这种事？’”
He said he'd wanted to apologize to me for many years but hadn't sought me out because he didn't want to reopen old wounds and because he hoped I'd forgotten it had ever happened.
他说多年来一直想向我道歉，但没找我，因为不想重新揭开旧伤疤，也希望我已经忘记那件事了。
"My biggest fear was that I had ruined your life," he said. "I was afraid that you would turn out to be a homeless drug addict or something, and it would all be my fault."
“我最大的恐惧是我毁了你的人生，”他说，“我害怕你会变成一个无家可归的瘾君子什么的，而那全都是我的错。”
I told him that while I wasn't I street junkie, I did have a tremendous fear of becoming a father. Because I didn't believe I'd be able to protect my child from people like him.
我告诉他，虽然我不是街头的瘾君子，但我对成为父亲怀有极大的恐惧，因为我不相信自己能保护孩子免受像他这样的人的伤害。
Becoming a father had changed his life, he told me. "I found what love really means," he said. "I used to think that love meant you just really liked somebody a whole lot. But when you become a father, you really understand what love is."
他告诉我，成为父亲改变了他的人生，“我找到了真爱的含义，”他说，“我过去以为爱意味着你只是非常喜欢某人。但当你成为父亲，你才真正明白什么是爱。”
I asked what he would do if he found out that someone had raped his son. He said, "I'd probably rip their head off."
我问他如果发现有人强奸了他的儿子，他会怎么做。他说：“我可能会撕碎他们的头。”
There's a scene in The Good, the Bad, and the Ugly where the gunfighter played by Eli Wallach righteously blows away a guy and then drops this pearl of murderous wisdom. "If you going to shoot, shoot. Don't talk. Because if you let them talk, you may not shoot."
在《黄金三镖客》中有一个场景，伊莱·沃勒克饰演的枪手正义地轰飞了一个家伙，然后说出了那句充满杀气的智慧名言：“如果你要开枪，就开枪。别说话。因为如果你让他们说话，你就可能开不了枪。”
And sure enough, as soon as I exchanged a few sentences with him, I didn't want to shoot him at all. Because I saw him as a frightened, damaged man. He wasn't the bogeyman any more, he was real. He begged my forgiveness. He swore I was the only one. All the experts say he was almost certainly lying. But then all the experts say it was extremely unusual for him to admit his crime to me, let alone his wife and parents. And he did at least make the admission to his parents. I checked.
确实，当我与他交换了几句对话后，我根本不想开枪射杀他了。因为我把他看作一个受惊的、受损的男人。他不再是那个“怪物”，他是个真实的人。他恳求我的原谅，发誓我确实是唯一的一个。所有的专家都说他几乎可以肯定是撒谎。但所有的专家也都说，他能向我承认罪行，更不用说向妻子和父母承认，是极其罕见的。而且他至少确实向父母承认了，我核实过。
I did not grow up in a religious household, but he did. Talking to him on the mall, I thought of this passage from Romans. "Do not take revenge, my friends, but leave room for God's wrath. for it is written, It is mine to avenge. I will repay."
我不是在有宗教信仰的家庭长大，但他是在那种环境中长大的。在购物中心和他交谈时，我想起了《罗马书》中的这段话：“亲爱的朋友，不要报复，要留出上帝愤怒的空间。经上写着：‘伸冤在我，我必报应。’”
When I had nothing else to say to the man who had raped me when I was seven, we parted ways. He blended into the crowd.
当我再没有什么话对这个在我七岁时强奸过我的男人说时，我们分道扬镳。他融入了人群。
David Holthouse is a reporter now living in Alaska. After his story was first published in 2004, his newspaper, Westword, was inundated with letters from people who had been molested as children themselves thanking him. Grateful, especially for the part of the story where he shows that it's possible to let go of your anger. So coming up, the most unromantic guy imaginable puts the rest of us to shame in the romance department. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
大卫·霍尔索斯是一位现居阿拉斯加的记者。他的故事在2004年首次发表后，他供职的《Westword》报社收到了大量曾遭受过童年虐待的受害者的来信，感谢他。他们特别感激故事中他展示出放下愤怒是可能的这一部分。接下来，一个最不浪漫的家伙将在浪漫领域让我们所有人汗颜。广告后回来，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Slow to React. Stories of people taking a very, very long time to deal with life-changing situations of one sort or another. We've arrived at Act Two of our show.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种相关的故事。今天节目的主题是“反应迟缓”。讲述的是人们花费很长时间来处理各类重大人生转变的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Isn't it Slow-mantic?
第二幕，这不是慢浪漫吗？
In this act, we turn to love. And in Sean Lewis' family, there was a legendarily romantic love story. It's famous in his family partly because the story unfolded over decades and across continents. But also because nobody can quit believe, even now, that out of everybody in the family-- there are four siblings-- out of everyone in the family, the one with the epic, swoon-inducing love story is Mark.
在这一幕，我们要聊聊爱情。在肖恩·刘易斯的家庭里，有一个传说般的浪漫爱情故事。它在他们家族中非常出名，部分原因是这个故事跨越了几十年和几大洲，也是因为直到现在，没人能相信家族中的四位兄弟姐妹里，那个拥有史诗般浪漫爱情故事的人竟然是马克。
Mark, the one sibling who was never wild or boisterous, the one who never tried to sneak into bars at 14. Sean Lewis tells the story.
马克，那个从不狂野、不吵闹，从未在14岁时试图溜进酒吧的兄弟。肖恩·刘易斯讲述了这个故事。
I asked my family how they would describe my uncle Mark. The word romantic did not come up.
我问我的家人他们会如何形容马克舅舅，“浪漫”这个词根本没出现过。
Spontaneous? I don't think-- hmm. Not really.
“冲动？”我不觉得……嗯，真的不算。
If you've spoke to anybody, Mark and his plans. There's a time we have to meet. There's a time we have to leave. There's a time we have to eat.
如果你和任何人谈论过马克和他的计划，就会知道我们见面有固定时间，离开有时间，吃饭也有时间。
My brother stands at attention on a regular basis.
我哥哥是个经常按规定行事的人。
When we were younger and at a family event, you didn't even know he was there. Because no parent ever yelled his name, ever. None of the aunts or uncles ever had to speak to him about don't say that or don't stand that way or run that way because he always was the perfect child. He never said no. He never went and yelled at his parents. He was always very adult. Always very adult.
当我们年轻时参加家庭聚会，你甚至不知道他在场。因为从来没有父母喊他的名字，没有阿姨或叔叔因为他说话方式不对或站立姿势不对而教训过他，因为他一直是个完美的孩子。他从不说不，从不对父母大喊大叫。他一直很成熟，总是很成熟。
This is a love story of my Uncle Mark and the women he's now married to, named Ha.
这就是我马克舅舅和他现在结婚的妻子——哈的爱情故事。
Right out of high school Mark joins the military. He loves it. He's stationed in Korea as an MP. And one day by chance, he meets a beautiful girl in a coffee shop, Ha. She's in college, waiting at the cafe with her cousin for an English tutor. Mark asks her out, they date, they fall in love. He's 20 years old. She's 23. He wants to marry her. And like a good son, he writes home about it to his mom.
高中刚毕业，马克就加入了军队，他热爱军队。他被派驻到韩国担任宪兵。有一天偶然的机会，他在一家咖啡馆遇到了美丽的女孩“哈”。她当时在读大学，和表姐妹在咖啡馆等英语家教。马克约她出去，他们约会并相爱了。他当时20岁，她23岁。他想娶她，像个好儿子一样，他在给妈妈的信里提到了这件事。
He wrote to me shortly after he was in Korea, and he said to me, "I met a girl, a beautiful girl, and I love her." And I didn't think he was long enough there to be in love with anybody. And he said, "I'm going to try bring her back to America with me." And I said, "I wouldn't do that if I were you." That's the last he ever talked to me about her.
他在韩国没多久就写信给我，说：“妈妈，我遇到一个女孩，很漂亮，我爱她。”我觉得他在那边还没待够，不可能爱上任何人。他说：“我想带她回美国。”我说：“如果我是你，我不会那么做。”那是他最后一次跟我提起她。
This is the first blow to his plans with Ha. We're a first generation Irish family, very matriarchal. And no one respects his mother more than Mark. He doesn't give up on bringing Ha to the US, but now he knows the family's not going to help. And then there's another complication. His sister, my mother, is in a crisis.
这是他与哈的计划遭受的第一次打击。我们是一个第一代爱尔兰移民家庭，非常母系化，没人比马克更尊重他的母亲。他没有放弃带哈去美国的念头，但现在他知道家庭不会支持他。接着又出现了另一个复杂情况，他的姐姐，也就是我母亲，陷入了危机。
I was going through the divorce. My parents were living with me in my home, and our house was going into foreclosure. And I was working as a waitress, and my father was working as a security guard at night. And we were not making enough money to take care of the house. And Mark sent us money every month to try to help us keep the house.
我当时正在经历离婚，父母住在我家，我们的房子面临抵押赎回权被取消。我当时在做服务员，父亲晚上做保安，我们赚的钱不够付房贷。马克每个月都寄钱回来，试图帮我们保住房子。
But the family's financial situation just keeps getting worse. And then on top of that, the military rotates Mark back to the US. They won't let him return to Korea. So he leaves the military and turns and all his attention to his family to help us survive. He moves to where we are in Denver.
但家里的财务状况每况愈下。更糟糕的是，军队把马克调回了美国，不允许他再回韩国。于是他退伍了，把所有注意力都转向家庭，帮我们生存下去。他搬到了我们所在的丹佛。
While he's caught up doing all of that, he stops writing to Ha. And during the time he's out of touch, Ha moves-- twice. The next time he tries to reach her, he can't find her. She's gone.
在他忙于处理这一切的同时，他不再给哈写信。在他失联期间，哈搬了两次家。下一次他尝试联系她时，已经找不到人了。她消失了。
Now comes the part of the story that I'm old enough to remember. The family moves to upstate New York to a very small town, Greenwood Lake, just north of the city. Mark becomes a police officer. And the family tries to get him dating, but it doesn't go anywhere.
现在到了我这个年纪还记得的部分。我们全家搬到了纽约州北部的一个小镇——格林伍德湖，就在城市北边。马克成了一名警察。家里人试图帮他相亲，但都无疾而终。
Like we belonged to the Irish Club. If there was a dance we'd invite him to come. And he'd come, but he never would dance. Actually, he used to do guard on the door. So no ruffians would get in. Where there was no ruffians.
我们那时属于爱尔兰俱乐部。如果有舞会，我们会邀请他来。他确实会来，但从不跳舞。事实上，他通常在那当门卫，防止捣乱分子进来，尽管那时候根本没什么捣乱分子。
Did anyone actually hire him to do this?
有人雇他这么做吗？
No.
没有。
The few women he does go out with don't last, and I could see why. His idea of a good date at the time was for him to watch the movie Stripes seven times and then bring a woman to the movie and quote the whole thing to her as it's happening. He wanted his dates to share his love of Irish military history and his interest in naming his first child Wolfgang. He'd lecture people about anything they were doing that seemed wrong to him. He didn't smile much. None of this went over well with the women of Greenwood Lake. So his social life was mostly us, his family.
他交往过的几个女人都没长久，我明白原因。他当时的理想约会方式是自己把电影《条纹》看七遍，然后带女伴去电影院，并在电影播放时把整部片子的台词全念出来。他希望女伴分享他对爱尔兰军事历史的热爱，还对给第一个孩子取名“沃夫冈”很感兴趣。他会对身边任何看起来不对的事情进行说教。他不怎么笑。这一切在格林伍德湖的女性看来都很糟糕。所以他的社交生活主要是我们家人。
When his days off, he would come. All you would have to do is walk into my mother's house and smell roast beef, roast potatoes, and we knew exactly who was coming-- Mark. I would say to my mother, do you know what my favorite meal is? And she'd go, no. But she knew what Mark's favorite meal was.
他休息的时候就会过来。只要走进我妈妈家闻到烤牛肉和烤土豆的味道，我们就知道是谁来了——马克。我会问妈妈：“你知道我最喜欢吃什么饭吗？”她会说：“不知道。”但她很清楚马克最喜欢吃什么。
Why do think she doted on Mark so much?
你为什么觉得她对马克那么宠爱？
Because he was alone. I think that's why. Because Mark was alone. And she felt like he needed more of a mothering touch.
因为他很孤独，我想这就是原因。因为马克很孤独。她觉得他需要更多的母爱关怀。
And this is Mark's life for 10 years. He dutifully supports the family by going every day to a job he doesn't like, with coworkers who despise him for being so by the book. He exercises. He goes home to his one room apartment. And on Sundays, he sees the family. And this is the Mark we think we know. Dutiful, straight-laced, family oriented. Probably never going to get married. We have no idea that this entire time Mark is pining for Ha.
这就是马克10年的生活。他每天都尽职尽责地支持家庭，去做一份自己不喜欢的工作，与那些讨厌他“按规矩办事”的同事相处。他锻炼身体，回到自己的单间公寓。周日，他见家人。这就是我们认为我们了解的马克：尽责、循规蹈矩、家庭导向。可能永远不会结婚。我们完全不知道，马克在这整个期间一直都在思念着哈。
I had a picture of us together.
我留着一张我们的合影。
This of course, is Mark.
那当然是马克。
And that was in my bureau in my bedroom every day when we were apart. I would wake up to that photo and I would go to bed looking it that photo.
我们在分开的每一天，那张照片都在我卧室的抽屉里。每天早上醒来，我都会看着那张照片；睡前，我也会看着它。
Did you think you were going to see her again?
你以为还会见到她吗？
I didn't really know. I really didn't know.
我真的不知道，我真的不知道。
And you were in Korea, and you were moving on?
你当时在韩国，你已经继续前进了吗？
Yeah, about two, three year later, I just had so much agony and so much missing, so I just feel like, oh my gosh. I couldn't wait anymore. So I actually buried him inside my heart and slowly, I forgot him.
是的，大概两三年后，我承受了太多的痛苦和思念，我觉得：“哦，天哪，我不能再等了。”所以我把他在心底埋葬了，慢慢地，我就把他忘了。
During most of these 10 years while Ha is putting Mark out of her mind, Mark is actively trying to find her.
在这10年里，当哈把马克从记忆中抹去时，马克却在积极寻找她。
Wrote letters. I put advertisements in Korean papers.
我写信，我在韩国报纸上登广告。
Oh really?
噢，真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And nobody in our family knew you were doing this.
我们家里没人知道你在做这些。
No. That was top secret.
没有。那是最高机密。
Did you just think that people were going to be not positive about it or give you a hard time?
你是不是觉得大家不会给予正面评价或会给你找麻烦？
I just didn't want to hear anything in reference to it. I knew what I wanted to do.
我只是不想听到任何相关的闲话。我知道我想做什么。
You needed no secondary opinions.
你不需要任何次要意见。
Right.
是的。
Which in our family are abundant.
而在我们家，意见多得是。
Abundant.
多得是。
Finally, a letter that Mark sent out reaches Ha. And six months later, Mark sees a letter back from her in his mailbox.
最终，马克寄出的一封信到达了哈手中。六个月后，马克在信箱里收到了她的回信。
Were you nervous at all?
你当时紧张吗？
No, I was not nervous.
不，我不紧张。
I'm amazed by this. I'm amazed that you seem so calm and confident. I would have been terrified.
我对此感到惊奇。你看起来如此冷静自信。我会吓坏的。
I saw that letter as a way out of the state I was in. That one way or another, I was going to close a chapter of my life.
我把那封信看作是我当时状态的一个出口。不管怎样，我都要结束我生命中的这一章。
So it was about either she was going to be your wife, or at least you wouldn't have to keep pining?
所以这要么意味着她会成为你的妻子，要么至少你不用再苦苦思念了？
That's exactly right, Sean. It was she was going to be my wife or I was going to move on.
完全正确，肖恩。要么是她成为我的妻子，要么我就此放下。
Mark asks Ha to come visit. She says she has to think about it. She takes a year.
马克请求哈来探访，她说她要考虑一下。她考虑了一年。
It takes about one year, because I have to think about if I start seeing him again, because I don't want to hurt anymore like before. But I miss him.
花了一年时间，因为我得考虑如果再见到他会怎样，我不想再像以前那样受伤了。但我很想念他。
So she says, OK, I'll meet you halfway in Hawaii. At which point Mark announces to the family out of the blue, I'm going to Hawaii to meet Ha.
于是她说：“好吧，我们在夏威夷中间地带见吧。”这时，马克突如其来地向全家宣布：“我要去夏威夷见哈了。”
I mean I was like, what? I was like, you're kidding. He never talks about private things.
我当时的感觉是：什么？你在开玩笑吗？他从不谈论私人事情。
Did you know about any of this?
你知道这一切吗？
I did know about Hawaii. And I didn't think anything would ever come of it. I really didn't.
我知道夏威夷的事，但我从没想过会有什么结果，真的没有。
Mark and Ha have a great time in Hawaii. And right away on this first trip together, he asks her to marry him. But Ha, in the 10 years they've been apart, has become this powerhouse businesswoman in Korea. She owns three gyms, trains people on the Korean Olympic team, has a house full of medals. She's gotten used to being single. So Mark works on her for another seven years. He calls. He writes letters. And every six months they meet up, have a great time, and he asks her to marry him again.
马克和哈在夏威夷玩得很开心。第一次旅行，他就向她求婚。但在他们分开的10年里，哈已经成为了韩国的一位商业女强人，拥有三家健身房，负责韩国奥林匹克队的训练，家里摆满了奖牌。她已经习惯了单身生活。于是马克又坚持了七年。他打电话，写信。每隔六个月他们就见一次面，玩得很开心，他又会求婚一次。
The family meanwhile, still has no idea how serious the relationship is because Mark isn't telling us anything, as usual. So the whole thing with this woman Ha whom we've never met, starts to seem like just another weird dating situation of Mark's. Another woman he'll see for a while, who will eventually move on.
与此同时，家里人依然不知道这段关系有多严肃，因为马克像往常一样什么都不说。所以关于这位我们从未见过的哈，看起来就像是马克的又一场奇怪的约会。又一个他交往一阵子，最终会分手的女人。
So year seven, what changed?
那么第七年，发生了什么变化？
You believe in God, right?
你相信上帝，对吧？
Do I believe in God? I do.
我相信吗？我相信。
I thought it's God work make me really quick change. Because I was very, very sick. My heart is pounding. It's like a double pounding, triple pounding. So I found out later, I have a whole check on my body, it's like I have thyroid. And my doctor say, you cannot continue your work.
我觉得是上帝的工作让我发生了剧烈的转变。因为我病得非常厉害。我的心脏猛烈跳动，双倍、三倍地跳。后来我发现，我做了全身检查，好像是甲状腺的问题。医生说，你不能继续工作了。
Ha is sick for weeks, and Mark calls her every day.
哈病了几个星期，马克每天都给她打电话。
Every day. Sometimes twice. He showed to me his love. Before I told you it's like I cannot see his love. He hugs me and kisses me and he say, I love you. It's not moving my heart. And then, but I was sick. He called twice a day and how is you doing? You have to have surgery in United States. My mind start moving. You know what? He really loves me, I believe, really. So I closed down my business, and I talked to my mom and my family. I'm going to United States to marry.
每天。有时一天两次。他向我展示了他的爱。之前我告诉过你，我感受不到他的爱。他拥抱我、亲吻我，说“我爱你”，这些都没能打动我的心。但后来我生病了，他每天打两次电话，问我怎么样。他说我必须去美国做手术。我的心开始动摇了。你知道吗？他真的爱我，我相信，是真的。于是我关掉了生意，和妈妈及家人商量后，决定去美国结婚。
18 years after Mark and Ha first met, Ha arrives in the US. And two days later, she and Mark get married at the Middletown Courthouse.
马克和哈第一次相遇18年后，哈抵达美国。两天后，他们在米德尔敦法院结婚了。
We're all there. Me, my mom, her brothers, my grandmother, the whole family. And Mark is in this tuxedo, and Ha is wearing a white dress and a Korean headpiece. And we're all stunned at how beautiful she is and at how happy they look together.
我们都在场。我、我妈、她的兄弟们、我祖母，全家人都在。马克穿着礼服，哈穿着白色的裙子，戴着韩国头饰。我们都被她的美丽和他们在一起的幸福感震惊了。
The comfortableness and the relaxed that he's with Ha is like he's with nobody else.
那种舒适和轻松的状态，他与哈在一起时表现出的样子，是他在任何人面前都没有过的。
I think my favorite moment was Mark dancing with Ha to Led Zeppelin. Who knew?
我想我最喜欢的时刻是马克和哈随着齐柏林飞船乐队的音乐跳舞。谁能想到呢？
I'd never seen him dance ever. He danced. And not the slow dance. He danced to Led Zeppelin.
我从没见他跳过舞，一次都没有。但他跳了。不是慢舞，他是随着齐柏林飞船乐队的歌跳的。
They are very much in love. I know that. I found that out shortly after that they really are.
他们非常相爱。我知道这一点，我在那之后不久就发现了，他们是真的相爱。
When you say you found that out, what was the final proof?
当你说是如何发现的，最终的证据是什么？
Because everything is her in his mind. Everything is Ha. You know what I mean? He can't believe he has her.
因为他心里的一切都是她。一切都是哈。你明白我的意思吗？他不敢相信自己竟然拥有了她。
I asked my grandmother recently if she regretted the letter she wrote after Mark and Ha first met. She said yes, but she didn't know Ha at the time. In some ways, she didn't know Mark either. None of us did. He was the tortoise in a family full of hares moving so slowly amongst his siblings' marriages, divorces, career changes that to us, it looked like he was hardly moving at all. But he knew exactly what race he was running.
我最近问祖母，是否后悔当初马克和哈刚认识时写的信。她说后悔，但她当时不了解哈。某种程度上，她也不了解马克。我们谁也不了解。他是那个家族奔跑者中唯一的乌龟，在他兄弟姐妹的结婚、离婚和事业变迁中缓慢前行，以至于在我们看来，他几乎没怎么动过。但他很清楚自己跑的是哪场比赛。
Sean Christopher Lewis is a playwright and a performer currently touring the country with two shows, Killadelphia and Just Kids . To find out when he's coming to your town, go to seanchristopherlewis.com
肖恩·克里斯托弗·刘易斯是一位剧作家和演员，目前正带着《Killadelphia》和《Just Kids》两部剧巡演。要查询他何时来到你的城市，请访问 seanchristopherlewis.com。
[MUSIC - "WHAT IS AND WHAT SHOULD NEVER BE" BY LED ZEPPELIN]
[音乐：齐柏林飞船的《What Is and What Should Never Be》]
Act Three, I'm Still Here. Slow to react is usually kind of an insult. You know, it's kind of a flaw, a failing. In this next case though, the things that are slow to react are cancer cells. And slow to react in that kind of situation is sort of how you'd want it. Jonathan Menjivar tells the story.
第三幕，我依然在这儿。反应迟缓通常被视为一种侮辱。这往往是一种缺陷或失败。但在下一个案例中，反应迟缓的是癌细胞。在这种情况下，反应迟缓恰恰是你想要的。乔纳森·门吉瓦尔讲述了这个故事。
Just looking at the numbers, Katherine Russell Rich should be dead. When you're diagnosed with stage IV breast cancer, the average life expectancy is two and a half years. You meet women who have lived 5 or 10, but beyond that, Kathy says, there's a tiny sub-category that lives 20 or 30 years. Just 2% of all cases.
看看数据，凯瑟琳·拉塞尔·里奇本该已经去世了。当你被诊断出患有四期乳腺癌时，平均预期寿命是两年半。你会遇到活了5年或10年的女性，但除此之外，凯西说，有一个极小的亚群体能活20或30年，只占所有病例的2%。
Doctors have no idea who will end up in that sub-category. Kathy's one of them. She's had cancer for 23 years, and she's lived with stage IV for 18. And just so it's clear, she's not in remission. The cancer has been sitting in her body, and the whole time she's been pounding it with chemicals of one sort or another. When you have cancer for so long, at some point, Kathy says it's not the first thing on your mind anymore, and you've got to deal with more ordinary, uncomfortable things. Like how you bring it up when you meet people.
医生根本不知道谁会进入那个亚群体。凯西就是其中之一。她患癌症已经23年了，带病生存了18年。需要说明的是，她并不是缓解期。癌症一直潜伏在她体内，而她整个期间都在用各种化学手段对抗它。当你患癌如此之久，在某种程度上，凯西说癌症已不再是你脑海中的首要大事了，你必须处理更多普通、烦人的事情。比如当你遇见新人时，该怎么开口。
I lie a lot about it actually. Because not everybody needs to know my business. Well let's say you and I were having lunch, and I knew it was something I was going to need to bring up at some point if we were to become friends. I think I might just say, you know, I've got this weird situation where I've had cancer for 23 years.
事实上，关于这件事我撒了很多谎。因为不是每个人都需要知道我的私事。假设你和我正在吃午饭，我知道如果我们成为朋友，迟早得提到这件事。我想我可能只会说：“你知道吗，我有种奇怪的情况，就是我已经患癌23年了。”
And usually the person will say something like, you're kidding. What kind? And then, I'll say I have this really slow-growing kind of cancer. I fall into this small sub-category of people who just live and live with the cancer. It just doesn't move as quickly.
通常对方会说：“你在开玩笑吧？哪种癌症？”然后我会说：“我得的是那种生长非常缓慢的癌症。我属于那一小部分能长期与癌共存的人。它发展得没那么快。”
It often brings out stories from them, which I like too. I like hear other people's stories. Not necessarily like, I've had people go, really? I've had fibroids for five years. And then, sometimes we get off on the wrong track like that.
这往往会引出对方的故事，我也喜欢这样。我喜欢听别人的故事。不一定非要……有些人会说：“真的吗？我得子宫肌瘤五年了。”有时我们就跑题到那儿去了。
Wait, what are fibroids?
等等，子宫肌瘤是什么？
I don't even know. But they're not in the same category as advanced cancer. But I have had that. And then you're in the position of having to hear about their fibroids. Which is not something I necessarily want to do.
我甚至不知道。但它们和晚期癌症不是一个范畴。但我确实遇到过这种情况。然后你不得不被迫听他们讲子宫肌瘤。那不是我一定想做的事。
Yeah because people are just trying to connect with you in some way.
是啊，因为人们只是想以某种方式和你建立联系。
I think in that case they just wanted to talk about their fibroids actually.
我觉得在这种情况下，他们只是想聊聊自己的肌瘤。
OK, so I looked it up. Fibroids are definitely unpleasant. But Kathy's right, not the same territory as terminal cancer. Anyhow, as you can imagine, in 23 years Kathy's tried pretty much every treatment there is. Some stuff they don't even do any more.
好吧，我查了一下。子宫肌瘤确实令人不适。但凯西说得对，和晚期癌症不是一回事。无论如何，你可以想象，在23年里，凯西尝试过几乎所有可能的治疗方法。有些东西现在甚至都不再使用了。
She started with the standard chemo, radiation, and a lumpectomy to remove the tumor. After that, her first doctor actually told her she was cured. She had a bone marrow transplant, which studies have since determined that for breast cancer isn't any more effective than conventional chemo. She was part of a gene therapy trial. She dipped into alternative treatments, including some purple herbal drops from a cowboy in Wisconsin who told her to soak her feet in them. She tried being vegan. That lasted three days. She tried a macrobiotic diet. Same problem, too many vegetables. What's helped her most is hormone treatments. They basically starve Kathy's cancer of the food it needs.
她从标准的化疗、放疗和肿瘤切除术开始。那之后，她的第一位医生甚至告诉她“治愈了”。她做了骨髓移植，但后来的研究确定，对于乳腺癌而言，这并不比常规化疗更有效。她参加过基因疗法试验。她尝试过替代疗法，包括从威斯康星州的一位牛仔那儿买的紫色草本药水，他让她用这个泡脚。她尝试过纯素饮食，坚持了三天。她尝试过宏量营养饮食，同样的问题，蔬菜太多。对她帮助最大的是激素疗法，它们基本上是把凯西的癌细胞饿死。
All those treatments mean she's a walking museum in the last couple decades of cancer treatment.
所有这些治疗意味着她就是过去几十年癌症治疗的活体博物馆。
Yeah, when I gone on those cancer message boards, I feel like some old-timer in Appalachia. Like they'll say, really, you had a bone marrow transplant? When I was first diagnosed with cancer, somebody had come out with this theory that if you put some ice helmet on your head-- they had these blue ice helmets for chemotherapy-- and you iced your head, it would somehow keep your hair from falling out.
是的，当我上那些癌症论坛时，我感觉自己像阿巴拉契亚的老古董。他们会说：“真的吗？你做过骨髓移植？”我刚被诊断出癌症时，有人提出一个理论，如果你在头上戴个冰头盔——化疗时他们有那种蓝色冰头盔——如果你给头部降温，这能防止脱发。
I'm sorry, and what does it look like? Does it look like a series of ice packs? Or I guess I sort of imagine like the way that a woman looks like when they get out of the shower and wrap their hair in a towel, but made out of ice packs. Or is it like a football helmet?
抱歉，那看起来像什么样？是像一串冰袋吗？或者我想象的样子是像女人洗完澡用毛巾包裹头发那样，但是由冰袋做的？还是像个橄榄球头盔？
It wasn't a football helmet. It was like somebody had, after a keg party, gone and gotten the remains and put it in a blue trash bag, and somehow figured out how to tape it to their head.
那不是橄榄球头盔。就像有人在狂欢派对结束后，收集了残余的东西装进蓝色垃圾袋里，不知怎么搞的把它粘在头上。
It didn't do anything for Kathy, but she's been in the cancer world long enough that there have been significant improvements in ice helmet technology. The Washington Post ran a story recently that quoted success rates between 76 and 90%. But for Kathy, the ice helmet was just one little funny step on her long, long breast cancer timeline.
这对凯西没什么效果，但她在癌症世界待得够久了，冰头盔技术已经有了重大改进。《华盛顿邮报》最近报道称成功率在76%到90%之间。但对凯西来说，冰头盔只是她漫长的乳腺癌时间轴上一个小小的搞笑插曲。
I long ago gave up the thought of cured. Cured isn't in my vocabulary. They just keep trying to keep you alive. And it's like you're surfing the cancer. You have to time when you think it's time to change treatment.
很久以前我就放弃了“治愈”的念头。“治愈”不在我的词汇表里。他们只是努力让你活下去。这就像在冲浪，你得把握好什么时候该更换治疗方案。
We mistimed a treatment last summer and the cancer just kind of exploded in my bones. It caused like nerve damage and stuff. And now I have some trouble walking. It was the first time I'd ever seen that happen where we didn't call it at the right time, and I could see, oh yeah, this is really dangerous if you're not timing it right.
去年夏天我们错过了一个治疗时机，癌症就在我的骨骼中爆发了。导致了神经损伤之类的，现在我走路有些困难。我第一次见到这种情况，如果我们没选对时机，就会看到：“哦，是的，如果把握不好时间，这真的很危险。”
Kathy says she doesn't understand why doctors aren't studying her and the rest of the 2% who have survived over 20 years to figure out what makes them different. She's as mystified as anyone that she's managed to live this long. Being a terminal patient for 18 years, your attitude towards it evolves. At some point you wake up and realize, you haven't died yet, and you have to adjust. Kathy remembers the day she was given her stage IV diagnosis. She had just switched oncologists, and she got a message saying she needed to come in right away.
凯西说她不明白为什么医生不研究她和其他2%存活超过20年的人，以找出他们的不同之处。她像任何人一样感到困惑，自己竟然活了这么久。作为一名末期病人18年，你对它的态度会演变。在某个时刻，你醒来意识到：“我还没死，我得做出调整。”凯西记得获知四期诊断的那一天。她刚更换了肿瘤科医生，收到消息说她得马上过去。
And I went in and she said it's all through your skeleton. And I just had this sense that, shouldn't someone call the police? I mean, I'd never been in a situation when there was no one you could call where they were telling you you're going to die. And I thought, maybe I should call my parents. But they couldn't do anything. And the police couldn't do anything.
我去的时候，她说：“这已经扩散到你整个骨骼系统了。”我当时的感觉是：难道没人应该报警吗？我的意思是，我从没处在这种境地：面对告诉你即将死亡的消息时，却没有人可以求助。我想：“也许我应该给父母打电话。”但他们什么也做不了，警察也做不了。
I went into this state of discordance where nothing made sense. And if something really terrible happens you can think, oh my God, I'm going to kill myself, or not necessarily seriously. But you can't even think that if you've just been told you have a year or two to live. Because that's the whole problem. Your body is killing itself. So I just would go into utter blackness every night and just lie there. So I think it took me maybe 14 years to get comfortable with the fact that I was going to be here. And now, how do I live a life after planning to die, and what do I do with a life now? I have to like argue myself back into life a lot.
我进入了一种矛盾的状态，一切都没了意义。如果发生了真正可怕的事情，你可能会想：“天哪，我要自杀。”不一定是当真的，但当你被告知只有一两年的生命时，你甚至连那种念头都不能有。因为这就是整个问题所在：你的身体正在杀死自己。所以每天晚上我都会陷入完全的黑暗，只是躺在那里。我想我花了大约14年才让自己习惯“我将留在这里”这一事实。现在，如何在计划死亡后活下去？在这个生命中我该做些什么？我不得不经常说服自己回归生活。
So what does that mean? Does that mean your friendships have changed?
那意味着什么？意味着你的友谊发生了变化吗？
Yeah. It means I'm not feeling like there's plexiglass between me and the world, basically. And I'll try anything. I might not have written a book, two books now, if I hadn't been sick that long. It's made me kind of fearless to have had it this long. And I just think, what's the worst that's going to happen if you do it? What's the worst that's going to happen if you let yourself believe that maybe you could stay alive? You know, the answer was, nothing.
是的。意味着我不再觉得我和世界之间隔着有机玻璃。我会尝试任何事情。如果我没病这么久，可能就不会写书了，现在是两本。生病这么久让我变得无所畏惧。我想，如果你去做了，最坏能发生什么？如果你让自己相信也许你能活下去，最坏又能发生什么？答案是：什么都不会。
We spoke a few weeks before January 15. It's a big day for her. Kathy's divorced. She and her ex-husband split up right before she got her initial diagnosis. But that date, the 15th, that used to be their wedding anniversary.
我们在1月15日之前几周进行了谈话。这对她来说是个大日子。凯西离异了，她和前夫在获得初步诊断前就分开了。但那个日期，15号，曾经是他们的结婚纪念日。
And it was my parents' wedding anniversary and my grandparents' and my great-grandparents'. So for a long time, that's what it was in my life. When the cancer came back, I got the news on January 15. So it's a pretty loaded date in my life. There's a great message board for advanced breast cancer patients on breastcancer.org. And I've now started going on the message board and just saying on that date, I'm still here. I'm alive, and I'm still here. And I want the women on there to know that there are people out there who live with this, and live for a long time. So I write and I get like hundreds of responses back. It's really difficult to do that every year knowing that most of the women aren't going to fall into that percentage. And I debated every year whether I'm doing the right thing.
那也是我父母、祖父母和曾祖父母的结婚纪念日。所以在很长一段时间里，它就是我生命中那样。当癌症复发时，我在1月15日得到了消息。所以这是我生命中一个充满重负的日子。breastcancer.org上有一个很棒的晚期乳腺癌患者论坛。我已经开始去那个论坛留言说：“我还在。”我活着，我还在。我想让那里的女性知道，有人确实能带着癌症生存，而且活了很长一段时间。我写下来，会收到数百条回复。每年这样做都很困难，因为知道大多数女性最终无法达到那个比例。我每年都在争论自己是否在做正确的事。
Am I making people feel bad? I don't want anyone to think, oh well, she's living and I'm not.
我是不是让别人感到难受了？我不想让任何人觉得：“哦，她还活着，我却不行。”
Just about a week ago there was a post under the name Kathy36 on the message boards of breastcancer.org. Kathy36 said, I'm writing from India to say that as of today, I've been alive 18 years with stage IV. If someone had told me then that I'd be in India, or anywhere 18 years down the road, I'd have thought they were deluded or being cruel. As I've mentioned before, there was no hope when I was re-diagnosed. And then, somehow there was. Just as cancer can take some unexpected bad turns, it can take some unexpectedly good ones too. This computer's going to go down any minute, so I'll end here. But not before saying, I wish everyone the most unexpected year in the best way. Much love, Kathy.
就在一周前，breastcancer.org的论坛上出现了一个名叫Kathy36的帖子。Kathy36写道：“我从印度发帖说，截至今天，我四期生存了18年。如果当初有人告诉我，我会在印度，或者18年后还在任何地方，我会认为他们是妄想或残忍。正如我之前提到的，当我复发诊断时，没有任何希望。然而，不知怎的，希望出现了。正如癌症会带来意想不到的恶性转折，它也可能带来意想不到的好转。电脑马上要没电了，我就写到这儿。但最后我想说，祝愿每个人都能迎来最意想不到、也是最美好的一年。爱你们，凯西。”
Jonathan Menjivar is a producer for our show. Katherine Russell Rich's latest book is called Dreaming in Hindi .
乔纳森·门吉瓦尔是我们节目的制片人。凯瑟琳·拉塞尔·里奇的最新著作名为《印地语中的梦》。
[MUSIC - "THIS YEAR" BY THE MOUNTAIN GOATS]
[音乐：The Mountain Goats的《This Year》]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Production help from Eric Mennel.
今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与制作。高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。埃米莉·康登是办公室经理。埃里克·门内尔提供制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he is definitely-- I feel so proud! He is definitely learning the lessons that we hope to teach with our show each and every week. For example, during today's show, he actually dropped into the studio during one of the breaks in the show to say to me--
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ的管理层监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你们知道吗，他绝对是……我感到无比自豪！他确实正在学习我们每周希望通过节目教授的课程。例如在今天的节目中，他确实在节目的空档期间溜进录音棚对我说了这句话——
I kind of noticed you were kind of getting a little rounder around the middle.
“我注意到你的腰部确实变粗了一点。”
And we know what that means. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们知道那意味着什么。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，继续收听《美国生活》。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。